mich beschäftigt heute abend dass die
Regierung seit 2018
1,4 Millionen Euro an Journalisten
gezahlt hat das geht aus seiner Antwort
der Bundesregierung auf eine Anfrage der
afd-fraktion hervor die Honorare wurden
in Journalisten für Moderation Texte
Fortbildung Vorträge und andere
Veranstaltungen überwiesen der
Bärenanteil mit
875.000 Euro ging ein Journalisten des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks weitere
600.000 € erhält eine Reporter privater
Medien die Journalisten wurden in der
Beantwortung der Anfrage aus
Datenschutzgründen mit Nummern wie
Journalist 73 aufgeführt Pleite Ticket
hat heute die Namen aufgedeckt laut
deren Recherchen soll allein die frühere
Tagesschau Sprecherin als erwachsen im
Jahr 2022 mehr als 12.000 € vom
Bundeskanzleramt und der Beauftragten
der Bundesregierung für Migration
Flüchtlinge und Integration für
Moderation Jobs bekommen haben auch
tagessprecher soll für die Regierung
gearbeitet haben 2019 moderierte sie
eine Veranstaltung Arbeitsministerium
mit Hubertus Hall das Ministerium zahlte
ihr
4.260 EURO 2020 dann eine Veranstaltung
und Wirtschaftsministerium das Honorar
soll sich auf
5.962 Euro beliebt belaufen haben und
warum ich das so sehr jetzt gerade auch
betone das sind 10.000 Euro für zwei
Moderation man muss jetzt hier mal ganz
ehrlich sein dafür müssen die
Steuerzahler in diesem Land doch im
Durchschnitt mehr als zwei Monate lang
arbeiten und deswegen auch meine erste
Frage an Herr steiniger wie kann das
sein also erstmal lies mal diese riesige
Zahl 1,4 Millionen und ist schockiert
dann schaut man sich die Honorare an das
war jetzt eine Recherche von pleitetiker
Frau Rakers und Frau zawages haben sich
den gegenüber noch nicht geäußert aber
wenn man dann sieht das Frau Rakers für
zwei Moderation 10.000 € kassiert haben
soll vom Staat jetzt mal hören wir mal
auf darüber zu reden ob es dann auch
Beeinflussung gab wie ist das denn
möglich was ist das für eine Gage also
meiner Sicht ist es viel zu hoch jetzt
brauchen wir nicht darüber zu sprechen
dass wenn jemand eine Arbeit macht dass
der dann bitte dafür auch bezahlt werden
soll und auch sie wenn sie dann da
irgendwo sind als Moderatorin arbeiten
sie ja aber ehrlich gesagt also als ich
diese Höhe gehört habe da habe ich auch
gedacht also das darf ja wohl nicht wahr
sein und ein zweiter Punkt ist glaube
ich noch wichtig das ist nämlich die
Frage was macht das eigentlich in den
Diskussionen in unserer Gesellschaft wo
ja viele auch sagen oh die Politik und
die Medien die hängen alle irgendwie
unter einer Decke und irgendwelche
Verschwörungstheorien da auch im
Hintergrund sind und dann sind natürlich
solche Zahlen und und 1,4 Millionen ist
ja schon wirklich sehr sehr hoher Betrag
ist natürlich dann super Belege für
diejenigen die sowas verbreiten ja die
Politik verdrossen die Sie angesprochen
haben nur noch 59% der Menschen im
besten Vertrauen in der Demokratie noch
einmal die Rückfrage an sie was macht es
denn auch vor allem auch beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk man hat
ja schon oft das Gefühl ob überhaupt
kritisch genug differenziert genug
berichtet wird hilft ist da das
Tagesschau Sprecherin Geld von der
Regierung von Moderation überhaupt nicht
also das Gegenteil ist natürlich der
Fall ich kann ja nicht irgendwie
nachmittags auf einer Veranstaltung der
Bundesregierung dann Fragen an die
Kanzler oder an den Minister stellen und
dann abends kritisch in der Tagesschau
richten oder in den Tagesthemen und von
daher kann ich sehr sehr gut
nachvollziehen dass ich die Leute
darüber aufregen ich ehrlich gesagt mich
auch Sarah du arbeitest hier in der
Politikredaktion bei Bild da ist
natürlich die erste Frage hat die
Regierung die denn auch schon mal Geld
angeboten für eine Veranstaltung
Moderation oder Training hat die
Regierung noch nicht Geld angeboten aber
das ist ja wahrscheinlich das Problem
wahrscheinlich würde sie es eher dem
Rundfunk anbieten wie man irgendwie sich
jetzt denken kann das ist ja so ein
Gefühl was man immer hatte wenn man die
Beiträge gelesen hat es ist mir viel zu
ähm unkritisch und es ist nicht
ausbalanciert in der Meinung und wie
bezüglich gewissen Themen umgegangen
wird und es ist viel zu linkslastik
tatsächlich auch ist und ich finde das
sieht man hier ganz gut wieder dieses
Gefühl was man hatte das wird hier so
bestätigt
was ist verwerflicher das Angebot oder
die Annahme ich finde ehrlich gesagt die
Annahme als Journalist weil man sich ja
schon überlegt wenn man telefoniert mit
einem Politiker aus der Regierung wie
sehr darf ich mich jetzt irgendwie mit
dem sympathisch gemein machen und wie
sehr halte ich noch Abstand von ihm wenn
ich irgendwelche Deals haben will oder
ähnliches was von dir ja die Ampel macht
jetzt zum Beispiel die ganze Zeit jetzt
also wenn die verhandeln was ein
Koalitionsvertrag steht und da hat jeder
natürlich eine andere Meinung und dann
muss ein Kompromiss gefunden werden und
dafür wird natürlich was anderes gegeben
und diese ganzen Hintergrundgespräche
ähm die man da immer erfährt da hat man
auch mal das Gefühl man muss jetzt die
auf Abstand halten weil vielleicht
verlangen die dann irgendwie ist man
Artikel positiv schreibt und ich glaube
das haben auch viele Journalisten dieses
Problem war ähnlichen Sachen
ich habe solche Deals auch unter Angela
Merkel wir offensichtlich ja wenn man
sich die Anfrage anschaut dann dann gibt
es das also schon länger das ist eine
Praxis die die ist aber nicht in Ordnung
und ich fand die die Frage ganz
interessant die sie gestellt haben ist
jetzt was ist sozusagen verwerflicher
also ich meinte das Politik natürlich
versucht dann irgendwie Veranstaltung
auch professionell moderiert zu haben
okay dass man so hohe Beträge zahlt ist
nicht okay ich finde es aber echt
schwierig dass dann Journalisten das
auch annehmen weil ich mache mich
natürlich angreifbar das ist die gleiche
Diskussion die wir im Übrigen beim Thema
Lobbyismus auch bei uns als Politiker
haben wo ja dann auch früher mal
Bundespräsidenten wegen Bobby Cars
zurücktreten
sie sagen Annahme schlimmer auch Annahme
schlimmer dann gehen wir doch einmal zu
Carsten Stahl was ist schlimmer Angebot
oder Annahme Regierung oder Journalisten
ich finde beides verwerflich zutiefst
auch zeigten dass die Abgründe auf und
wo bleibt dann die Objektivität aus
meinem Arbeitsfeld ich bin
Kinderschützer es gibt ja auch
Kinderschutzorganisationen sehr viele
und es gibt
kinderausschutzorganisationen die werden
staatlich unterstützt und wenn ich dann
nämlich höre dass ich Eltern bei mir
melden und sagen ja der und der
kinderschutzverein hat mir gesagt wenn
sich lieber an Herr Stahl der kann da
anders sprechen handeln wenn ich nämlich
an einem Futtertrog stehe und gefüttert
werde dann werde ich die Hand die mich
füttert nicht beißen und genau das ist
es ich kann doch keiner erzählen dann
wenn ich solche Beiträge bekomme dass
sie dann Objektiv bin und dann wenn es
drauf ankommt kritische Fragen stelle
dann werde ich doch und das sehe ich an
die Debatten die Fragen die da gestellt
werden da frage ich mich immer wo bleibt
eigentlich das nachhaken wo bleibt die
Kritik nein das sind für mich sind arme
Personen die vielleicht auch ausgewählt
werden weil sie besonders hamster sind
und dann bekommen sie halt ihren
Schmackes dafür soll es ja so gewesen
sein kann das Herr Scholz vor allem auch
sie favorisiert hat da kommen natürlich
schon der Verdacht auf angenehme fragen
ob sie die stellt aber was wäre für sie
eine Lösung sie haben gerade
Kinderschutz für eine angesprochen Herr
Steininger hat gesagt naja professionell
moderiert muss es schon sein Arbeit muss
ich schon lohnen wie wäre denn zum
Beispiel eine Lösung dass das vielleicht
ein gespendet werden muss was die
Regierung Zeit von dem Moderatoren die
es machen also grundsätzlich finde ich
es also schon ich sag mal so auch für
einen Journalisten die eine Ehre dann
dort überhaupt moderieren zu dürfen ja
so dass man für seine Arbeit eine
Unkostenpauschale bekommt ist auch
normal aber die Frage ist immer die Höhe
ja und grundsätzlich wäre das zum
Beispiel eine Möglichkeit dass man sagt
man müsste man würde das Spenden oder
und das wäre mir ganz wichtig wenn man
doch Journalisten hat wir haben so viele
Journalisten im Land dann doch bitte wie
so ein Schachteln
ja keiner von der Bilder oder von
anderen Zeitung mal dann auch die
unbequem nicht einfach nur die die sagen
wir mal ja Hans haben berichten und so
ein bisschen als ich dachte immer nett
die hofj letzten gewertet werden ja die
auch gut bezahlt werden und immer
gestreichelt werden also ich persönlich
sehe das ja auch warum wenn er Menschen
wie ich nicht in irgendwelche
öffentlichen Debatten eingeladen kann es
daran sein dass ich unbedingt Fragen
stelle und mich nicht davon beeinflussen
als ob dann Bundeskanzler sitzt oder
sonst wäre sondern ich will dass die
Bürger vertreten werden und das möchte
ich auch von Journalisten und vor allen
Dingen von denen die durch die Bürger
bezahlt werden fragen wir einmal einen
Burger hier in der Runde der allein
schon mit seiner Anwesenheit zeigt wie
wichtig in dieses Land ist wir kommen
danach gleich darauf gleich zu sprechen
aber was empfinden sie als Bürger wenn
Sie das hören wenn Sie die Summen hören
1,4 Millionen aber auch die einzelnen
Gehälter von 6000 € für eine Moderation
also ich glaube für den normalen Bürger
ist es schon schwierig nachzuvollziehen
wie überhaupt die Gehaltsstrukturen die
man irgendwo liest die bei den
öffentlich rechtlichen gezahlt werden
und das noch oben drauf ich weiß und
heute nicht finden wenn ich heute sehe
dass eine kassieren bei Aldi oder Lidl
an der Kasse was die verdient und solche
Summen werden umgeschmissen dass die
damit umgehen kann das versteht doch
kein Mensch mehr
Steininger was ist die Lösung bei für
Sie
ja ich bin es ja eigentlich ein
Verfechter der Marktwirtschaft und von
daher bin ich nicht so fürs Deckeln von
Gehältern ich glaube aber es ist ein
Unterschied wenn der Staat sozusagen bei
Veranstaltungen bezahlt also das wäre
glaube ich ein erster Punkt dass man da
einfach Regularien macht so und so viel
soll es dann halt eben sein erster Punkt
zweiter Punkt fand das was Herr Stahl
eben gesagt hat eigentlich ganz gut dass
man zum Beispiel dann sagt wir nehmen
vielleicht auch Nachwuchsjournalisten
mit rein wir nehmen vielleicht jetzt
muss er dann vielleicht nicht Hochglanz
die Präsentation der das der Tagesthemen
sein sondern man gibt auch dem
nachwuchsmart deine Chance und gibt ja
genug Journalistenschule absolut und das
werden übrigens auch ein besseres
Zeichen dann der Bundesregierung im
Sinne der Fachkräfte Förderung und das
könnten so zwei Punkte sein wie man das
auflösen kann ist auf jeden Fall gut
dass wir jetzt drüber sprechen weil noch
mal mein Punkt ist er der was ist denn
die Wirkung in die Bevölkerung hinein in
der gesamten Diskussion
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk und
Politik ist denn jetzt das Vertrauen in
die Medien steht das auf dem Spiel wir
sind uns ja schon sicher es werden ja in
den nächsten man immer mehr Namen nach
oben kommen ich glaube schon dass diese
Sache riesig wird ja können die Bürger
überhaupt noch den Medien Vertrauen
schwierig schwierig ich finde diese
Liste wirkt fast wie so eine
Lieblingsliste und wir hatten ja auch
eine Lieblingsliste quasi vom Rundfunk
als sie Studie rauskram wie positive
negativen Beiträgen über Politikern
berichtet wurde über CDU und FDP was
negativer über SPD und Grüne was positiv
war und sie haben sie haben ihre
Lieblingspolitiker und offensichtlich
haben die Regierung auch
lieblingsjournalisten und genau das
weckt nicht gerade Vertrauen in die
Bürger und das Vertrauen steht schon
länger auf den Spielen nämlich vor allem
seit der flüchtlingskrise als auch sehr
regierungsnahen Angela Merkel berichtet
wurde was auch damit zu tun hatte das
Angela Merkel auch sehr geschickt immer
mit Journalisten gut konnte und er sie
eingeladen hat und manche auch bevorzugt
hat deswegen schon an mit dem
regierungsflieger wer da sitzen darf und
so weiter oder wer sie mal beraten darf
auf dem Kaffee und
und dann eine corona-pandemie wo das
natürlich noch mehr verstärkt hatte man
oft das Gefühl dass die Journalisten so
nah dran an der Regierung berichten als
gehörten sie fast irgendwie zu einem
Gesundheitsministerium und dieser
kritische Geist war eine Zeit lang
ziemlich verloren mit mit Journalisten
von Politikern
Journalisten machen auch gerne selfies
mit Politiker
weil wenn ich jetzt auf einen Kaffee
treffe mit einem Politiker um irgendwas
zu erfahren ja als
Hintergrundgespräch oder sonstiges dann
würde ich ja das quasi geheim halten
weil es geht ja erstmal niemanden was an
das ist eigentlich das Grillo davon und
ich glaube auch der Politiker gegenüber
eigentlich sowas eigentlich immer
Standard der will jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt dass jemand weiß mit welchen
Journalisten er sich so trifft ja wobei
ich muss geschehen ich habe ein
journalistische Lehrer mein Fehler
gemacht da habe ich andere Steuer als
ersten Spitzenpolitiker dann habe ich
ein selfie gemacht das gepostet und dann
gab es richtig Ärger in der Hand ins
Bett Redaktion zurecht übrigens
rückblickend deswegen Journalisten den
Fehler in meinen Augen immer machen
gestanden in Journalisten da nichts mehr
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
nehmen unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
ihren
falls Sie